[Musica]
questa sera vi vorrei parlare del dei
grandi temi che vengono discussi
quotidianamente ormai da mesi come il
metaverso gli NFC e la Digital art e il
Web 3 la define le criptovalute
ovviamente no ne sentiamo tanto parlare
in questi ultimi mesi e viene posta
l'accento solamente su un aspetto
tecnologico e finanziario soprattutto
per quanto riguarda il mondo cripto il
mondo Web 3 viene vista solamente
l'aspetto speculativo che sicuramente
oggi è l'elemento principale ma non
viene visto diciamo il nocciolo della
questione No l'aspetto più filosofico
antropologico e sociale dall'altro lato
invece abbiamo il metaverso che viene
invece visto solamente come un futuro
distopico Stasera invece vorrei porre
l'attenzione su quello che per me
rappresenta questa grande rivoluzione
ci troviamo immersi nella quarta
rivoluzione la rivoluzione digitale
citando Luciano floridi uno dei filosofi
contemporanei più attivi legati al mondo
appunto della tecnologia che descrive le
nostre vite in un ibrido tra online e
offline tra reale e virtuale tra
digitale e fisico quindi appunto
un'ottica di online viviamo
nell'infosfera ossia nell'era dei dati e
Nell'era dell'informazione pensiamo alle
Big Tech quindi Google Facebook e
quant'altro il loro business model e
siamo noi La nostra identità i nostri
dati loro vivono su questo per fare poi
leadv
l'Iper storia invece cos'è È un modo per
descrivere il contesto ehm in cui siamo
immersi che è super rapido No in cui chi
si ferma è perduto ma ovviamente la la
la fretta ovviamente è cattiva
consigliera eh partiamo dal metaverso il
metaverso è una grandissima rivoluzione
sociale economica e politica il
metaverso Che cos'è È un ambiente
virtuale in cui noi utenti eh veniamo
Appunto ehm ci identifichiamo in un
avatar Quindi la nostra riproposizione
digitale della nostra persona e abitiamo
degli spazi quindi diciamo È come dare
vita all'immaginazione E non certo senso
ovviamente il tema è diventato no
mainstream con Zuckerberg che non è che
si è inventato il metaverso ha preso un
trend che era attivo degli anni 80 e
soprattutto negli ultimi negli ultimi 20
anni con Second Life e con tanti
progetti cripto è andato alla ribalta e
ha cambiato il nome di Facebook in meta
decretando quindi il metaverso sul
social del futuro
che cosa cambia cambia la nostra
percezione del tempo e dello spazio Noi
siamo fisicamente in un luogo e
indossando un Oculus quindi un visore di
realtà virtuale entriamo appunto in
questi ambienti virtuali e viviamo Eco
sistemi di questo tipo Questa è stata la
prima sfilata di moda su The centralland
che è uno dei dei Traversi più attivi in
questo senso
andiamo però a vedere le radici del
metaverso le radici lievemente verso le
possiamo diciamo
incanalare nella letteratura di
Stephenson e nei film di fantascienza
come Blade Runner e Video Player One
negli ultimi anni ovviamente negli
ultimi 20 anni i videogames sono
diventati il media Entertainment più
diffuso soprattutto per le nuove
generazioni No ehm E che cosa Cosa sono
i video che aspetto principale generano
uno stato di Flow eh eh un senso di
coinvolgimento che le persone provano
giocando ai videogiochi perché si
sentono Eh partecipativi si sentono
attivi sono protagonisti di una storia
ma non è che la vedono al cinema la
vivono cioè devo risolvere quel problema
devo compiere quella missione devo
salvare la regina la principessa dal
castello devo battere il mio amico a
FIFA che pensa di essere più forte di me
e ovviamente io ho 24 anni sono stato
influenzato nella mia infanzia da dei
videogiochi giocando a me dello sfondo
che diciamo ehm raccontava la storia
degli alleati No nella Seconda Guerra
Mondiale Qual'era la mia attenzione
oltre a diciamo un elemento ludico Ma
c'è anche un elemento di dotaiment
perché io ho scoperto cosa fosse gli dei
prima ancora di studiare la scuola ho
scoperto la loro Maldive ho scoperto
tantissime cose stanno giocando a questi
videogiochi ho scoperto San Gimignano
San Gimignano io non la conoscevo
giocando ad Assassin's Creed ho scoperto
a San Gimignano ho conosciuto
Machiavelli ho conosciuto Cesare Borgia
ehm addirittura a scuola magari non te
ne parlo neanche di queste figure quindi
che cosa voglio dire ehm voglio dire che
io ho vissuto queste ecosistemi con una
sorta di implementazione della mia
esperienza non come una Mera
sostituzione della mia vita reale E
soprattutto ovviamente l'entertainment è
importante Ma guardate Anche l'aspetto
di educament e quindi della mia
esperienza vorrei che questi metaversi
fossero vissuti secondo quest'ottica
il metaverso è la goccia in un oceano
c'è una rivoluzione gigantesca che
quella del Web 3 passi dal web 2 che è
quello dove abbiamo No Instagram
Facebook Google e quant'altro al web 3
che ti rende più decentralizzato perché
Adotta una tecnologia che quella della
blockchain che rende appunto
decentralizzato ehm l'intero ecosistema
E quindi cosa succede cambia tutto
cambia il modo in cui scambiamo valore
attraverso le cripto valute scambia il
modo Cambia il modo di applicare il
regolamentare delle leggi e delle regole
a disintermediando E appunto andando ad
applicare questi Smart Contract questi
contratti intelligenti quindi se io
voglio vendere una casa un'altra persona
non ho bisogno di un notaio che
certifica la transazione ma eh vive la
fiducia tra me e l'altra persona e
quindi possiamo andarci a scambiare un
bene cambia il diritto di proprietà di
un bene digitale ehm ovviamente ehm
questa presentazione questo PDF è un
file che è duplicabile e replicabile
attraverso gli nfp posso rendere unico e
raro questo PD quindi questo file e
commercializzarlo e potenzialmente
venderlo cambia il modo di organizzare
le società attraverso le dao sono delle
organizzazioni autonome decentralizzate
che cambiano e metaversi hanno
all'interno delle Dau dove l'utente non
ha più una leadership centralizzata
piramidale no figlia di questo
capitalismo esasperato Ma vabbè crea una
leadership appunto decentralizzata in
cui le decisioni vengono automatizzate e
le regole codificate dagli Smart
Contract e i cittadini quindi diciamo
gli utenti che popolano questo
ecosistema ehm possono votare e fare
delle proposte per il bene prima comune
e poi ovviamente anche il bene
individuale ehm e queste attività
vengono remunerate con dei token Quindi
come se fossero i punti fragola
dell'Esselunga tanto per capirci ehm
La partecipazione è uno dei temi più
interessanti che possiamo trovare nel
lavoro di studio azzurro uno dei
collettivi artistici digitali più
importanti in Italia che negli anni 90
appunto ha sperimentato l'utilizzo delle
nuove tecnologie attraverso l'arte
Questa è un'opera del 95 che si chiama
tavoli che è stata presentata alla
triennale di Milano Dove appunto
troviamo un'opera fisica quindi questo
tavolo è fisico un tavolo possiamo
toccare su cui è proiettata un'opera da
un diciamo un'immagine che è questa
questa figura femminile
statica nel momento in cui lo spettatore
toccava il tavolo fisicamente l'opera si
azionava E appunto andava a creare
appunto diciamo un movimento che appunto
in questo caso eh questa donna che si
lamentava cosa succede qua cosa tagliamo
Qual è la la Diciamo quello che traiamo
come conseguenza ehm che ehm attraverso
l'arte digitale o comunque attraverso
l'arte eh studia Azzurro ha creato fibra
ottica dello spettatore che non è più
passivo ma è attivo non è più spettatore
ma aspetta autore ed è coproduttore
dell'opera d'arte e inoltre il tema
dell'interattività ovviamente non c'era
non c'erano gli iPhone non c'era il
touch screen nel 95
Questa è un altro esempio di un
collettivo invece tedesco che si chiama
arcom che ha creato un'installazione che
si chiama Terravision praticamente
l'utente poteva andare a sorvolare
l'intero globo e andare in ogni luogo
che
prediligeva quindi andare a Bangkok
andare a casa sua ovviamente che cos'è
questo è Google Earth Google Maps è
quello che utilizziamo tutti i giorni
infatti c'è un film bellissimo che si
chiama il codice da un miliardo di
dollari che spiega come Google ha rubato
il codice da questi artisti sprovveduti
che ovviamente hanno fatto causa a
Google al momento non l'hanno vinta
quindi noi utilizziamo tutti i giorni
un'opera d'arte sostanzialmente ehm
chiudo con questo video Invece ehm che
racchiude un'esperienza che abbiamo
fatto con la mia startup che si chiama
Elison d'arte per collegare il mondo
dell'arte fisico con il mondo digitale
Questa è appunto questa installazione
che abbiamo fatto fisicamente all'arco
della pace che diventerà prossimamente
Il primo monumento entrare del metaverso
quindi appunto con quest'ottica di
online quindi unire fisico e digitale e
con questa sorta di chiave di lettura
Più legata allelutainment quindi in un
futuro mi immagino che l'arco della pace
non lo studieremo più su un libro ma lo
studieremo entrando all'interno di
questo metaverso vi lascio con questo
uno l'ultimo punto del nostro manifesto
che potete trovare sul nostro sito che è
appunto l'arte Intercetta al futuro e
propone una visione innovativa del
presente grazie
[Applauso]